في افاده جديده لاخر التحديثات حول
المعطيات ما بعد زلزال تركيا
ومباشره اذهب الى فرح زمان شوقي مراسلتنا
من مديريه اداره الدائره الكوارث
والطوارئ فرح اذا العنوان العريض لن نفقد
الامل هذا ما قاله نائب الرئيس التركي
ماذا عن المعطيات الاخرى
بالفعل سلمى طالما انا الحديث يجري عن
انقاذ المزيد من
الاحياء والناجين من تحت الانقاض سيستمر
هذا الحديث المرتبط بعدم فقدان الامل
واستمرار عمليات الانقاذ نائب الرئيس
التركي من هنا من افاد ولكن من قاعه او
غرفه تنسيق العمليات يقول بان عمليات
البحث والانقاذ قد انتهت في بعض المناطق
وهذا الامر ادى الى ارسال الطواقم التي
تعمل هناك الى اكثر المناطق تضررا وهي
انطاكيا فيها تاي الجميع الان يتجه الى
هناك والانظار ستنصب خلال الساعات القادمه
على تلك المنطقه التي اعلن من قبل بانها
واحده من اكثر الاماكن تضررا يتحدث ايضا
عن ارتفاع اعداد المباني التي تمت
معاينتها من قبل فرق خاصه ان ارسلتها افاد
الى تلك المناطق يتحدث عن اكثر من 200 الف
مبنى
ويوجد عدد لا باس به من المباني التي ما
زالت صالحه للسكن بالتالي الحكومه هنا
تتحدث عن اطلاق منصه الكترونيه سيكون
المواطنين قادرين على
التحقق من وضع منازلهم وما ان كانوا
قادرين على العوده اليها في وقت لاحق ام
لا وهذا بطبيعه الحال سلمى سيساعد كثيرا
في مساله جهود الايواء في المراحل المقبله
اذا نائب الرئيس التركي
يتحدث بشكل الرئيس عن مساله الانقاذ لكن
بالنسبه للاعداد سلمى بحسب ما اعلن عنه
قبل مؤتمر نائب الرئيس كان في الحقيقه
الزياده التي حصلت مرعبه في الحقيقه ساعات
طويله مرت لم يتم الاعلان عن حصيله جديده
لكن عدد القتلى بات يقترب من 30 الف قتيل
بفارق خمسه الاف شخص عن اخر احصائيه تم
الاعلان عنها في وقت سابق الفارق كبير
للغايه في لم يتم ايضا الاعلان عن زياده
في عدد الجرحى اذا الزياده كانت في عدد
القتلى فقط بحسب
افاد الى جانب ذلك ارقام جديده تتعلق
بالهزات الارتداديه اكثر من 2400 هزه يعني
300 هزه في يوم واحد فقط هو اليوم ازدادت
هذه الهزات وهذا ما تؤكده بيانات افاد الى
جانب شهادات عديدين متواجدين في تلك
المناطق ومنهم مراسلينا الموجودين في
الميدان ويشعرون بهذه الهزات المكرره بشكل
كبير خلال اليوم اضافه الى ذلك سلمى
الاجلاء زادت اعداد من تم اجلائهم من تلك
المناطق لتزيد او لتقترب من مئه وخمسين
الفا لكن في السياسه سلمى اود ان اتطرق
هنا الى اهم ما جرى وهي زياره امير قطر
حيث التقى بالرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
وكان اول زعيم يصل الى تركيا بعد حصول هذه
كارثه ليؤكد بان قطر ستقف الى جانب تركيا
وستوصل المزيد من المساعدات سلمى شكرا لك
فرح الزمان شوقي مراسلتنا من انقره